denn so wie es ist vielleicht was was
ich eigentlich gar nicht herausfinden
wollte um ehrlich zu sein und ich weiß
auch nicht wie ich damit umgehen soll
nichtsdestotrotz ist es wichtig auch mal
sowas aufzuklären nowitzki scheint es
ist nicht so wie ihr denkt im ersten
dreiviertel von diesem video das bin ich
oder zumindest dachte ich das einmal wir
schreiben den 19 04 und es erreicht mich
eine nachricht von meinem manager
sebastian er schickt mir den link zu
einem instagram profil aber dieses
instagram profil ist etwas besonderes
denn während dieser theorie in köln
deutschland sitzt könnte diese story
imitat mit ganzen 16 tausend follower
auf der ganzen welt niedergelassen sein
und sein unwesen treiben doch was der
identitäts tief im schilde führt dass er
weitaus mehr schaden anrichtet als
einfach nur mit meinem namen likes
abzugreifen und warum er damit 16
tausend follower anlocken konnte das
alles weil sie zu diesem zeitpunkt noch
nicht das profil ist nämlich privatmann
muss zuerst eine anfrage senden um alle
inhalte zu sehen
dieses video wird unterstützt von safe
disk und dachte mir abonnierte aber
dachte ich mir macht das doch nicht von
meinem account aus dann war ich dass ich
es bin
dann macht es doch von dem fake account
aus das heißt ich habe ein fake account
erstellt und mit diesem tag account
wurde ich auch angenommen er hat mir
auch eine anfrage geschickt die nehme
ich aber erstmal noch nicht an ist es
viel krasser viel viel krasser als ich
mir nur vorstellen könnte das heftigste
es aber er hat einfach 17 tausend
follower und wir schauen jetzt mal rein
was da so alles gibt
also das echt komplett weiß was zu sagen
okay aktien - und so weiter und so fort
und ich haben renner wieder von mir
einfach ein placement von hier wäre
dafür das muss ja ein bot sein oder er
hat hier einfach actually 11
einschreibung kopiert nee das kann herr
bord sein weil der post erfuhr alte
bilder das ist megageil 2 laux 66 1 lag
dann muss eben als mega gebaut ist ein
logischer weise werden sonst etwas
17.000
also ich merke schon welche richtung das
geht es geht so ein bisschen in die
aktie ein bitcoin richtung also
irgendwelche bitcoin blablabla produktes
das investieren 5000 dollar verdiene
94.000 euro bringen
daraufhin boxen wie whatsapp was da
schreibt jemand alex die tu ju hua model
studierenden pictures and while you're
follow us on display is that your
brother keiner looks like you hate heißt
alex das scheint jetzt private bilder zu
sagen ich weiß nicht ob das wirklich gut
ist wie ist er das hat er erst später
angefangen meine identität zu klauen gut
zu sehen in ihrem büro dass sein board
guckt euch mal diese abonnenten follower
waren
jetzt interessiert ist die website ja
ich gehe mal drauf
das wären dann will die nummer das wird
eine wilde apropos nummer bevor ich aber
jetzt diese whatsapp nummer anrufe
halten wir einmal fest der account um
dem es sich handelt hat viele follower
er verlinkt auf eine dubiose webseite
diese seite schauen wir uns später
genauer an der account hat eine whatsapp
nummer angegeben über die er eine
fragwürdige software vertreibt und
scheinbar leute abzockt wie man hier
sieht fragen ihnen sogar leute danach
und vereinen vielleicht darauf rein
der strippenzieher hinter diesem account
heißt scheinbar alex und hat bevor er
sein account zum thema rehfelde gemacht
hat augenscheinlich ganz normale bilder
von sich gepostet in seinem netzwerk
sind nicht nur andere accounts die
ebenfalls follower kaufen oder diese
durch irgendwelche anderen maschen
ergaunern sondern auch alte bekannte er
wurde wohl von seinem kumpel tim
verraten der in den kommentaren ebenso
schockiert war wie ihr über die
komischen bilder die plötzlich gepostet
wird auf teams frage hin ob ich sein
bruder sei antwortete account inhaber
übrigens mit ja
das ist ganz schön viel ich weiß nicht
wo ich anfangen soll ich würde sagen wir
nehmen als aller erstes mal die antrag
jahren die erd- und geschickt hat und
fragen ihn ob er uns coachen kann
und kurz darauf nimmt er kontakt mit uns
auf er ist sogar zuvorgekommen und
schreibt hallo wie geht es dir sagen
dass ich dir einfach so schreibe aber
ich wollte wissen ob du lust hast von
zuhause geschäfte zu machen lust zu
chatten ja dann schreiben wir noch mal
sorry dass ich so spät reagieren
ich habe da eine nachricht zuerst nicht
gesehen ich würde liebend gerne waren
staus geld berlin passte mainzerin mit
business opportunity senden
naja mal schauen was passiert
meine antwort kam viel zu spät und
überraschung der account wurde
mittlerweile lahmgelegt entweder
freiwillig oder durch instagram
administratoren gelöscht ist unsere
mission bereits jetzt gescheitert den
betrüger zur rede zu stellen immerhin
enthält account nun keine information
mehr und sogar der name der normal bei
den instagram profile hier oben steht
ist weg durch zufall habe ich auch schon
das nächste indiz gefunden
denn obwohl der account gelöscht wurde
finde ich den nachrichten von euch ja
immer noch und da steht jetzt zwar auf
den ersten blick auch keinen namen mehr
aber wenn man sich dass man hier oben
sieht wird mir da plötzlich was ganz
komisches zss becker unterstrich fx ja
und wenn man zss becker sucht ohne das
fx da hinten weil der account wurde er
bereits gelöscht kommen wir auf dieses
profil und da jetzt kommt geschockt
damen wieder unseren dubiosen alex und
wir haben ja eine gebildet die auch auf
dem profil des tumors gepostet wurden um
dem profil finden wir den gleichen link
die gleiche wertung freuen und da würde
ich sagen die nehmen wir machen genau
unter die lupe
diesmal finde ich nicht nur den sitz der
firma in texas usa an sondern auch eine
telefonnummer
bei der wir mal anrufen könnten
vielleicht wissen die ja was hier abgeht
und hier ist er wieder alex becker laut
internet recherche ist harris aber
wirklich ein erfolgreiches unternehmen
ich war bereits drauf und dran angemalt
einen termin mit highlights zu buchen
als mir die idee kam mal nicht nur das
unternehmen sondern auch den ceo alex
becker selbst zu googlen und der ist
tatsächlich ein youtuber mit 700.000
abonnenten
hätte mir auch vorher auf sein können
und ich wollte jetzt schon ansätzen zum
schreiben aber was ist wenn er doch der
schritt in die rente ist was ist wenn er
mit solchen methoden einfach seine firma
groß gemacht hat die firma jetzt einmal
dann wirklich toll aber er trotzdem noch
diesen ringen dieser organisation
kontrolliert darum gehe ich jetzt noch
mal auf nummer sicher und reverse image
search noch mal all diese bilder hier
aber nach weiterer recherche stellt sich
diese these als haltlos heraus harris
und alex becker waren also eine
sackgasse
ich meine wir sollten auch als ausgeben
wollen aber wer steckt denn nun dahinter
unser hauptverdächtiger ist also selbst
opfer der täter scheint weiter entfernt
denn je
aber wir haben ja noch unsere
geheimwaffe whatsapp und die nutzen als
auch und damit er nicht mal ein echter
nomad habe ich mir da auch eine fade
handynummer erstellt und ein fake
watches profil hat mich daniel genannt
und mal einfach klischeehafter weise
inhalten 3er bmw reingemacht ich glaube
damit kaufte mir ab dass ich mega
interesse an seinen business wissen ok
ich kannte das gespann das
eingeschränkte das ist alabama ist ein
weiteres indiz okay ich sehe sogar ein
profilbild einen laptop mit trading zeug
und es ist sogar unternehmens account
häufig schon geöffnet ich schreibe jetzt
hey ich habe deinen instagram platz
gefunden in dem es ums online geld
verdienen und trading geht die suche
schon seit langer zeit nach der
richtigen software
deswegen will ich da gerne mal darüber
hören finden so abgeschickt ich bin mega
gespannt über die whatsapp
beziehungsweise handynummer haben wir
auch herausgefunden dass unser
zielobjekt angeblich im us-bundesstaat
alabama wohnt ein hammer in dieses netz
fragen geantwortet oma in codes hh geil
gemacht
nice connection with you schön dich
kennenzulernen bevor wir weiter machen
nicht eine perfekte erklärungen gebe wie
man online passives einkommen verdient
will erst mal wissen wo ich wohne
zeichen ist ja auch offensichtlich habe
auch ein münchner kennzeichen war meinen
alten treiben dem profilbild dass das
wild das ist richtig aufregend
das ist also der hund ich schreibe also
gerade mit dem hund der sich als nicht
ausgegeben hat man handy lieber aus
älteste trick im buch kann ich mir die
nachricht nämlich noch mal auf meinem
start welche mir anschauen ohne dass er
sie dass sich online binden kann man so
machen schöne antwort zu recht wegen
würden sagen okay komplett schreibt
grundlegende wahrheit ist dass du
investieren muss um geld zu verdienen
you don't say das ja profitiert habe ihm
geschrieben
das problem ist zu wissen woran man
investieren soll welches dogs welche
coins investiert schon seit einem jahr
aber ich mache die ganze zeit fehler
natürlich einfach komplett glatt gelogen
was ich mache überhaupt keine fehler
beim es tieren aha das ist echt kurios
dass ich gerade einmal mit kriminellen
schreibst du änderst gefühl er ist
genauso wie ich gerade am handy nächste
nachricht schreibt direkt holy shit
schreibt das was jetzt los
hast du bisher investiert na gut also
falls screenshots zu sehen will müsste
ich ja eben wirklich etwas zeigen
hh er warnt mich hier vor spammern und
ich glaube die also die nachricht kam so
schnell ich habe das gefühl dass die
einer kopie pace war
ich habe geschrieben ich habe so ein
bitcoin und soundso viele theorien und
er schreibt glauben ja bitcoins
überrannt von betrügern die versuchen
deinen cash zu klauen irgendwie muss ich
den kerl später noch zur rede stellen
und am besten irgendwie nach dem
telefonat fragen oder so ich mache mich
x h da der scam weiterhin betrieben wird
obwohl der account gelöscht ist können
wir davon ausgehen dass das nicht
freiwillig geschehen ist sondern durch
eine band von instagram selbst also der
letzte mahlzeit möchte jetzt einmal dass
ich mit coin an der adresse schickt ihr
mir sind eigentlich ziemlich geil habe
ich bock drauf aber ich will doch
eigentlich mit dem telefonieren so darf
ich mal geschrieben habe ich bock
geschickt haben wir die adresse dann
stehe ich das geld drüber aber hast du
vielleicht noch mal zeit für ein kurzes
telefonat damit ich auch sicherstellen
kann dass ich möchte menschen medien
bestimmt nicht zur rede stellen
beim telefonat nanny auf gar keinen fall
jetzt ist es aber mal spannend oder sich
aufs telefonat oder sagt er
oder hat er jetzt rein und blockiert
mich oder so ja wenn wieder geschickt
und gespielt
über schützen mister m börsig dachte das
wäre toni mit dem ich gerade schreibe
ich wollte doch das coaching von thomas
scheinbar hat der kollege nicht so
richtig lust mit mir zu telefonieren
naja ich habe jetzt aber mal dass ich
vielleicht ein bisschen mehr investieren
wollen würde damit er so richtig schönen
bock hat sondern er vielleicht doch lust
hat auf dem telefonat kommt noch etwas
geschrieben wert von 6000 euro und die
würde ich auch gern direkt überweisen
damit ihnen jetzt richtig schön das
wasser muss nach läuft aber ich will
halt einfach auch dieses telefonat ab
[Musik]
ok airbus an russland
das thema identität einmal in friends
new pictures und meint sogar pixis vor
fate of you have a fake instagram profi
ja und da genau aufgelegt aber ich hab
seine stimme
h ich konnte ihm actually noch geld auf
seine bitkom adresse überweisen
wir machen jetzt richtig will dass ich
die positive aber machen zu sehen was er
denkt und dann will ich ihn dazu
überreden den face call zu machen damit
diese wieder typ aussieht oder wäre
spannend so wird können wir von 100 euro
let's go jetzt senden
ich hoffe mein investment lohnt sich ich
will nämlich nicht die 20 prozent der
mir verspricht weil man sein gesicht
sehen ich habe ich 100 euro geschickt
und schreibe ich ihm dann dass man uns
jetzt bisschen glück spielen das kann
nicht sein dass der bock auf mehr geld
hat das ist dann zu einem video chat
kennen wo ich dann mal sein gesicht
sehen kann oder er macht sich jetzt
einfach aus dem staub zürich auch sein
dieses video wird unterstützt von sap
das als freiberufler selbständige oder
unternehmensgründer werden einem in
deutschland echt einige steine in den
weg
aber unser heutiges sponsors der ist
schon mal einen der dicksten außen weg
das thema wohnung steuern und
buchhaltung die meisten von euch denken
dabei wahrscheinlich einen dutzende
ordner voll mit papierkram und
stundenlanger zahlen schieberei aber mit
sap sieht das eher so aus man nimmt
einfach einen rechnungs gelegt und
scannen den parteien oder zieht ihn als
pdf einfach per drag drop reihen selbst
erst geht es dann einfach automatisch
aus dem scan oder der pdf die
rechnungsnummer den rechnungssteller den
betrag und das datum dann kann man ganz
flott eine kategorie auswählen und hat
sofort ohne stress perfekte ordnung
statistiken und sogar eine einnahme
überschussrechnung in echtzeit man sieht
also anhand von graphen die gute
aktuellen monat läuft und wie das ganze
jahr im vergleich zum letzten zum
beispiel probiert es jetzt über den link
in der beschreibung 2 wochen lang
kostenlos aus ohne dafür irgendwelche
zahlungsmethoden angeben zu müssen und
wenn es dann behalten wollte spalte mit
dem kot tommy 4 m sogar noch 50 prozent
auf eure ersten vier monate pauli schiff
der jamaikaner screenshot geschickt von
den bitcoin die der erhält heute allein
1 4 x 120 dollar dann nochmal 300 dollar
damals 90 dollar dann nochmal 300 dollar
und das alles an
tag kann einfach an einem tag mit der
masche 800 dollar verdient und das macht
er hier gibt man jeden tag ich befürchte
dass das halt nicht nur youtuber sie hin
die dem das geld gerne gegeben
hobbs zunehmen befürchtet es in echt
leute die da hoffen dass sie da geld
machen
heute sendet niemals irgendwem einfach
so geld in der hoffnung dass ihr euch
mehr zurückgeben oder älteren link
geschickt ich habe sein vertrauen
dann werden 100 euro geschickt und
dadurch haben sich anvertrauen hermann
link zu seiner vier maschinen geschickt
zum trading website immer schauen was es
damit auf sich hat mein ziel ist er
hauptsächlich aber in eine webcam zu
kriegen oder per facetime mit dem zu
coachen wir schauen uns mal diese
website an sehr seriös auf jeden fall
ist kommt keine komische cookie abfragen
ziemlich klischeehaft hier ist eine
nummer ist dass die nummer mit den fall
schreiber er wird auch das des games und
hier steht das ist es ja überrascht mich
komplett aha also ich hab jetzt im
gericht gefunden wo diese website schon
häufiger einer fake identity beschuldigt
wurde
das wäre in zehn wenn dann noch mehrere
leute arbeiten würden wenn es ein
richtig krank scam wäre wenn es ein
richtiges netzwerk werden wir hier auf
die schliche gehen tage lange recherche
stunden langes hin und her schreibt mit
dem betrüger und alles läuft am ende auf
diesen einen moment hinaus
[Musik]
ok ich werde jetzt ihnen sagen dass ich
jetzt 3000 euro investieren will damit
er richtig bock hat dann wenn ich ihnen
aber sagen dass ich davon noch ein video
call machen wollen würde dann würde ich
auch wirklich weiß dass dann menschen
endlich finden so gespannt aber wenn ich
jetzt einfach gleich den dein gesicht
sehen könnte potenziell hat mir
geschrieben mir so video call ich hab
dir mein wort gegeben
bevor ich jetzt mal 3000 euro gehen weil
ich das du mir ein video call gibt es
gibt nichts schlimmeres als die
gewohnheit von zweifel zweifel teilt
menschen es ist ein gift das
freundschaften trend und aufbricht es
ist ein dorn der reizt und schmerzt ist
ein schwert das tötet plötzlich
shakespeare wollen oder was okay ich
hoffe jetzt anfällig macht es einfach
oder aufgelegt man kann da nicht
telefonieren weiter seine trainingsorte
beeinflusst okay ich habe geschrieben
wir daher nicht letzte köder
[Musik]
ich habe aber ich hab ein bild vom tod
himself main
was ist das für ein video geworden er
ist ein paar 70 jahre alt aber das
schwarz des eigentlich nie hingekriegt
habe ich wollte eigentlich mit dem video
chatten aber er wollte das auf sinken
und hat einfach nicht reichen sagt ja
okay wir müssen doch nicht video chatten
kann hier hast du beweist wo ich
persönlich meine nutzernamen auf dem
zettel hoch halte und meinen bitcoin
account nur 14.000 euro drauf waren ich
wollte da sind so richtig schön das
wasser seinen mitbürgerinnen mund
zusammenläuft hatte ich ihnen so ein
bisschen druck noch gemacht ja und dann
haben bild geschickt mit einem zettel wo
dann ein nutzer name draufsteht lustiger
wahnsinn war diese alternativen nämlich
genau der gleiche typ der vorhin das
testimonial gemacht hat das heißt er
sich wahrscheinlich ein paar selber das
festival gemacht weil er halt einfach
keine leute hat die ihm testimonial
machen und dann habe ich so ein bisschen
die erpresser methoden rausgeholt könnte
man kritisieren aber hey das ist
investigativer journalismus hat wirklich
und roman geschrieben hey heute geht ein
video online auf einem kanal mit fast
700 tausend abonnenten
wenn du die paar fragen die ich hass
antwort ist dann werde ich überall
zensieren dann noch mal deinen namen
deine adresse und wollten sofort deine
bilder also nicht passieren jetzt kommt
man natürlich sagen ja okay es kann
natürlich auch sein dass er einfach das
bild wie photoshop hat von diesem alten
mann mit dem zettel könnt wirklich sein
dachte ich auch aber dann hat das aus
dem jet gelöscht diese nachricht wurde
gelöscht schade dass es schon auf meinem
handy gespeichert war und deswegen jetzt
dieses video natürlich den kerl trotzdem
zensiert da man ja nie 100 prozent
wissen kann ob das jetzt stimmen
vielleicht wird auch photoshop aber es
geht schon echt echt aus und er hat auch
gelöscht also hat schon motiv ne
überhaupt nicht geil wir haben auch
gesehen geld am tag verdient bis zu 1000
euro jeden tag einfach wahrscheinlich so
ein 70-jähriger knacker hatte der jungen
leute hopsten
der wurde jobs genommen das einzige was
ein bisschen dagegen spricht dass der
kerl am telefon jetzt nicht unbedingt
sich alt angehört hat und jetzt auch
nicht übrigen das beste englische konnte
hat das widerspricht jetzt den noch ein
bisschen das ist komplett extrem kurios
ich habe absolut keine ahnung das ist
alles was ich weiß
wie gesagt ich habe jetzt auch nicht vor
der rechtliche schritte einzuleiten der
sitzt halt wegen wo sonst wo in amerika
oder gar nichts machen
jetzt gerade
ein echtes bild von sich oder von seinem
fuß geschickt und scheinbar ist es nicht
sehr alt und hat dann auch im video call
gemacht und es wirklich nicht der alte
tut ich habe nicht aufnehmen können also
das ist gerade viel zu schnell um das
war vor drei sekunden einfach probiert
aber trotzdem an
[Musik]
all you have yourself a crowd of people
away we go fake account who created the
account or the company is still in other
persons identity cocreate des account
[Musik]
erteilt
aber diesen screenshots folge in denen
die person ja offensichtlich jeden tag
mehrere hundert dollar verdient und auch
vielleicht diesen monitor schlappen der
mir geschickt hat zufolge kann es
natürlich auch alle selbst einmal eine
ausrede
wissen denn der sony pictures der
mannschaft scanning okay was ist gerade
passiert alter water act schwer ich weiß
überhaupt gar nicht mehr was ich machen
soll
ich habe ja noch ein bisschen
nachgedacht über das was gerade passiert
ist und ich weiß immer noch nicht was
das klo war es könnte eher zahlen dass
der tod einfach basic i in einem
riesigen netzwerk irgendwo wirklichen
ghana ist und einfach in der du bist ein
scheiß situation ist wo ich halt
eigentlich gar nicht böse darauf sein
kann aber es könnte natürlich auch sein
dass er das jetzt einfach nur genutzt
hat als neue masche ich weiß nicht ich
kann diese person jetzt irgendwie nicht
vertrauen ich will aber jetzt auch
natürlich nicht mehr so siegessicher und
ja ich kann mich jetzt nicht wirklich
darauf freuen dass wir das rätsel gelöst
zu sein es ist trotzdem eine wichtige
botschaft was auch immer ihr da jetzt
mit nimmt das internet ist weder ein
wilder platz wenn ich mehr weiß dann
gebe ich euch bescheid
[Musik]
an dieser stelle nochmal vielen dank an
selbst ihr dieses video unterstützt habt
der link zur smarten
buchhaltungssoftware ist jetzt eine
video beschreibung obwohl jetzt gerne
diesen kanal und wollte mir auch gerne
auf einem echten instagram account und
die nächste
[Musik]